[Music]
[Applause]
applause applause hello and welcome back
to the break room this is our daily live
show that keeps you updated on all the
nerdy news you need to know coming up on
the show today an upcoming quake in the
ncu I had an upcoming click last night
oh Jesus
I'll check on you next time we'll get
her after I left
we get a new look at Shazam too it's
time for some K inspiration on the show
uh and we make our our quantumania
Easter egg post-credits scene picks we
we we set him in stone here today who's
we you might ask do I have a mouse in my
pocket I do but also on the show today
we got koi Chandra it's been a month I
missed you guys let him out we let him
out of his cage the shirt's a
post-credit cnts oh a little tease
uh pointing out the t's is Jessica
Clemens I'm not trying to be that person
but when you shake the table too much
the cheese might crumble oh the cheese
my crumble what's that cheese we'll get
to that in a second but first we gotta
get to Tommy Bechtel and just call me
Tim Allen in 1993 cause I'm putting it
all on the line today come on very
timely uh you may wonder what this plate
of charcuterie is here in front of me
well we you know there was a lot of
chatter in the chat yesterday about
redemptions on the show we haven't had
them for a while we've been very busy
but you begged for the redemptions to
come back so we've obliged today I just
looked at it don't look at it too hard
uh we we've we've assembled a little
yucker yum mycology Edition okay in
honor of The Last of Us check it out if
you haven't on HBO uh for every hundred
dollars we receive in super chat today
we'll roll the die we got a little die
here uh and we'll eat either a tasty
cheese or mushroom or a nasty cheese or
mushroom you want to give them a
demonstration of I'm not like a freebie
Jessica let's just tell them tell them
some of the cheeses so um
so we have cheddar cheese with Scotch
bonnet chili and red peppers portable
mushrooms sliced mushrooms Olive garlic
parsley mushroom medley with the bomb
sauce blue cheese
Brandon's favorite Rock Fort Rockford
Rockford's a very stinky very stinky
delicious cheese that one's like the
most moldy of the old yeah it's pretty
moldy there's a heavy mold mold the
fungus we looked it up folks I like
I like blue cheese with chicken wings
but blue cheese on its own is a truly
disturbing
disgusting thing and weird that we eat
it well let's make Tommy eat some cheese
I just hope I get the mushrooms and only
the mushrooms we've already got super
chat from God kingdom saying big head
gang
doom again
uh so yeah every hundred dollars in
super chats will roll the die we'll put
our taste buds on the line uh and none
of these mushrooms are psychedelic at
least they weren't purchased as
psychedelic mushrooms you never know any
mushroom could be ready to pop off in
any second I just dropped a little bit
of LSD on each one oh my gosh
credit scenes
I did a line of the Gorgonzola okay uh
speaking of Tommy doing lines it's time
for some headlines hey foreign
before we get into our main discussion
today we did get a new poster for Shazam
Fury of the Gods folks there it is
beautiful whoa there's Fury there's Gods
it's all happening it's all happening
can I get that back up on the screen
real quick I just want to soak that took
it in Tommy soak it in so we've got um
uh who's the young lady in the back yeah
who's the one all the way back she's
from uh West Side Story
yeah
it's that Trio of goddesses yeah the
tagline is oh my God they were cute at
Comic-Con they sent a video and the
three of them were all like oh hi drinks
chemistry they were like adorable oh
there's so many hijinks So Much
Chemistry a trailer is set to come out
sometime tomorrow oh well we're on we're
on notice for that
yeah we've had a Shazam first trailer
this will be our Shazam second trailer
the movie comes on March do we think
they lean so the first trailer uh the
one that's in theaters right now leans
pretty heavy into the DC shared Universe
right I'm really curious if the second
one's like oh we're over here now I'm
hoping the second one has like Wonder
Woman it has
and then they apparently shot all these
cameos then they cut them and then
Aquaman was shooting at Ben Affleck
scene which apparently they cut so I'm
really curious when they start
advertising if they're leaning to or fro
all right because James gotten sitting
on that announcement 6 days left I know
we James Gunn promised us a slate all
right preview of this slate in January
yeah we're running out of days we're
running on a date uh I mentioned to
Quake earlier uh people if you live in
the Los Angeles area you may have been
woken up last night from a little
shaking it was a earth 4.0 four point
something and now it was a 4.8 or 4.8
yeah uh well agents that's not the only
Quake I want to talk about today Tommy
because Agents of Shield Quake after
actress Chloe Bennett implied on Twitter
that her character might be making a
return to the MCU they know okay some
someone was was uh disparaging her
goodness yes yeah she she shot back
maybe as a result of being woken up by
the earthquake yeah because maybe
searching Twitter for the term quake and
saw someone talking her name what if it
was possibly it was just an incident and
then she's like oh [__] everyone's gonna
read it everyone's gonna realize we've
all put out that tweet and been like oh
I should know what my boss doesn't need
to know I was up this late
uh or you know we all have our regret
tweets I wonder if like you know she got
woken up by the earthquake I assume she
lives in the Los Angeles the TMZ if you
will the 30 mile Zone she gets woken up
She searches earthquakes she's like not
seeing what she likes I'll search Quake
I was also Quake maybe someone's talking
about me yeah what did they say about me
she got into it you're gonna eat those
words now Quake is
famously a mutant and in Marvel Comics
agents of shields
the Mist they never said the m word
funny oh she went in through Terror
Genesis which is more of an inhuman
situation yes which is
a mutant yeah and now Miss Marvel was a
a an inhuman it was now a mutant I think
at the time they couldn't say mutant
right fox or whatever Channel it was so
or it was it aired on Fox but it was a
Disney show right Who aired on ABC
that's right so it was a Disney shows
they brought the inhuman comments could
not make new moon so they made the
Inhumans and then they tried to make the
mutants which never came out but I I
think that maybe they'll do what they
did with Miss Marvel and they like play
with that continuity a little bit yeah
uh you know Agents of Shield people have
their their feelings about the show I
think it's kind of been implied that
it's in a separate Universe separate
timeline because the final episode we
saw the triskelion in DC not demolished
right that had been demolished in Winter
Soldier implying this is a whole new
place and the dark code looked different
there play it looks very different they
had their own Ghostwriter a lot of stuff
was happening and that could work for
the the avenging of it all because
Coulson like that the way they brought
him back and killed him five times
there was a and now that ghost writer is
Tommy and The Last of Us oh that's right
maybe they share a universe maybe it's
all shared folks maybe I'm Tommy maybe
I'm a ghost rider maybe I'm the last of
us
ride them ghosts next headline in an
interview with sfx magazine we were
talking about this yesterday too Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania writer Jeff
loveness shared some of the comic book
variants he used to inspire his King the
Conqueror uh in the upcoming film saying
quote I got way into the ramatet and
Scarlet Centurion stuff that's the joy
of the character he's just this infinite
snake eating infinite Tales a man
literally at war against himself he also
went on to say I certainly Took a ton
from the comics but the joy of these
movies is you get to do you get to put
some of yourself into it and do 100 if
you do 100 Comic Book adaptation people
know all the tricks and what to expect
you have to use that as a foundation and
then throw a curveball uh he he
basically wants Kang to be like this
interesting character that people will
recognize some things but he could still
like subvert our expectations right yeah
uh now Coy we know you know a lot about
all these kangs and all this stuff uh do
you have a feeling about what all this
can mean this interesting quote you were
saying earlier like this this makes the
movie way more interesting to you yeah
this quote to me as like a comic nerd
like this is the best trailer they could
have given me like I love the trailer
Frant man but this like describing as an
oraboris like the snake eating its tale
of Kang I think this implies maybe
they're going with one of the more
modern storylines where he's wanting to
find a timeline where he gets to be with
Ren Slayer so uh Jackson Lansing just
wrote a Ken comic I think it came out in
2021 maybe early 2022 that basically was
describing like he has to be a conqueror
because all he wants is love and he
keeps failing it at finding a place
where he can be with his beloved so he
just accepts that he's evil and becomes
a conqueror in the trailer there's a bit
of somberness to Jonathan Major's
performance there's a bit of like sorrow
and you see in the trailer especially
the the San Diego Comic-Con one that he
says like have I killed you before and
it seems almost like we'll have done
that a lot like I'm why why is he going
forward what else is there to conquer
what else there to do so I think there
has to be something one to connect us as
an audience and loves the great unifier
like loves all there is so you want to
have that thing for the audience to feel
but also maybe he's trying to go through
all these different continuities to find
a way he can be with her and fails and
he also says to Scott time something
that was taken from both of us that's
all I can give you but he wants that
time back so maybe it's time with his
and there'll be a parallel between like
the Paul Rudd paternal relationship with
his relationship with his brother they
build a lot more time with the person
they love and I could easily see that
being a way to make Kang more
interesting because he got this guy for
five movies you don't want to be a one
note villain obviously Jonathan Majors
is not going to play in one note but we
need a story that's big enough and
ramatut is you know a god figure in
Egypt we have pretty well established
Egypt in Moon Knight and we have pretty
well established gods that could be an
element we have Scarlet Centurion who
basically is a relative of seemingly
both doom and uh Richards like Reed
Richards like somehow through time they
intermingle so it'd be interesting if
they introduce Doom as some sort of
element of like he's a relation to him
so all of these things kind of I mean
the continuity in comics is bananas but
you could away I mean Comics it's
straight it's a straight line but you
could meet maybe like five different
kangs in this film and then we could
have a few of them carry on and we could
even meet different versions of them
because we see the one sleeve in
Jonathan majors and some of the trailer
he's he's bi-sleeved and others uh I
could easily see it be a thing where we
have different markings and they need to
mark them so Scarlet Centurion he has
one of the most different outfits and I
think this all leads to a mortise I
think the thing that secret Wars is is
he succeeds to a level maybe he gives up
on getting to rensslayer and he just
becomes the ultimate conqueror which is
a mortise and that could be what secret
Wars kind of replaces or uh doubles down
on beyonder with but I do think this is
how we get to doom and I do think that a
multitude of Jonathan Majors which we've
already met one and he who remains is
what we're getting to hopefully that
made some sense I it got it it does make
sense it's just
this is the whole cane concept to me is
so hard to put your brain around that
these people are there's all these
variants of Kings Born and that like
they are just destined to become Kang no
matter what or they figure out that
they're Kang and being a Kang doesn't
for me it's like you think of like a
variant of someone and you're like oh
it's the same person but you're like no
it's not it's just the same concept so
like you're like the consider or the
citadelics the the Kings yeah has like a
female Kang there's like an Android
Cannon like it's like Nathaniel Richards
isn't the Kang we know but he's the
great the 31st 23rd generation which is
from the 30th Century right descendants
of King right but time travel means they
can live at the same time and also with
the Kang element you can also introduce
like the Council of reads you can also
buy way of Kang introduce read Richards
and Doctor Doom like this opens up a
great can of worms for continuity in
good and bad ways and then you've also
got what if which might have other kangs
you've got he who remains we've met but
he wasn't even Kang he was was a
good-ish version warning us about Cactus
yeah is this King in quantumanium is he
going to be our main King I think you
kill off your first Big King or do you
have him stick around as the big Kang I
think you're just gonna love him forever
because you know everyone loves their
first everyone loves their first king
you never forget your first king I think
there's at least three kangs in
quantumania I think we get more okay you
see them multiple yeah I think we could
lose one k but there's more Kane to go
more King there's plenty of Kings I
don't like this innuendo
three more Kings Will Spring out well
the Scarlet the scar Centurion right
like he's a king-esque person who like
uh he really he's good at like
manipulating The Avengers and kind of
getting them to do what he wants being a
puppet master and we know we're gonna
get some sort of Avengers
assembly of these characters we don't
know who those characters are yet but in
Kang Dynasty and like Secret Wars so
that's that that makes a lot of sense
right and I would think that you'd want
to introduce a king here that is one of
your main Kings and I think the Council
of Kings will be a predominant fixture
of Kang Dynasty I think that can I think
maybe we lose a lot of kangs in Kang
Dynasty which leads to a mortise in
secret Wars I think there could be like
we took out all these kangs we did it
we're Victorious and kind of like
Infinity war to end game you realize
that big big daddy Kang you haven't even
met yet so like after all the kangs he
taken out there's a moment of like
slight celebration and then amortis
comes in and that launches into your
horse and maybe they need to maybe the
way they gather all the universes is
that's the only way to take out Kang
because Kang has time travel abilities
but he also has the ability to split
multiverses so I've been wondering if
this is the reason that all these
universes feel kind of separate maybe
that's why we have shield and we've
we've heard from Kevin feige from the
beginning by the end of this all of the
discrepancies will make sense what if
we've already had different multiverses
we've already had these different things
that Kang has been causing searching out
the right Paul runs searching out and
this could be the beginning of
discerning which of these multiverses is
even canon in canned in Canada
but I think that we'll find out a lot of
things about phase 4 or as early as
February with Ant-Man but I think it's
going to be like here's two answers
here's 10 questions yeah and I think
that's what leads to Secret Wars is all
those universes like Fox and Sony all
those things might be the only way to
take out a mortise they need the might
of every avenger from all the
multiverses to take out a time and
conqueror they need the c-suite of
several different movie production
Studios together together the chief
marketing officers are the only ones
capable of pulling this off I I love the
The Mention Of Rama Tut here because in
Moon Knight right we saw there was one
of the guys that fights moon now he's
got like the Rama Tut figure on the back
of his jacket
um and Moon Knight is a series that you
know it sits in the timeline on Disney
plus I don't trust that timeline at all
we know like the GRC exists is
referenced in uh Moon Knight the global
repatriation Council as a result of post
blip so we assume it takes place
someplace after the blip but otherwise
it exists like outside of time it
doesn't really reference a lot of the
rest of the MCU I would love with that
show it was a glimpse into a future
we're not at yet where the end result of
quantumania when they get back out they
come here the result of that film will
have been King escaped and became Rama
tight and changed the whole history of
the US and it's very like Back to the
Future Part too even though they said
Back to Future time travel is not real
in the MCU the Earth that depends in the
the Langs and the pims and the van dynes
all come back to is not the Earth they
left and it has been changed much like
in uh the Loki series when Loki comes
back to right uh the TV8 he's the only
one that knows it's different they'll
come back they'll know that like there
never was a rama Ted that's not a real
thing and it's like no the rabbit's real
and we've never heard of The Beatles
okay and then Scott Lang writes
yesterday
but I I would love that to be like a
little reveal like a show we already saw
is actually another that's what I think
it's going to be the results it's also
the ultimate like deus ex machina right
like you've got a character that
literally could rewrite reality in time
so any continuity can fold into itself
like there could be a reason that
Spider-Man ended at the Christmas tree
and Hawkeye wasn't involved this all
could be a tease that all things have
been like slightly disparate well
they've gone back and changed the color
of the Statue of whether it's true it
was a dirty rotten move Disney plus a
dirty rotten move you showed the Statue
of Liberty and Miss Marvel we knew it
took place after Spider-Man and it was
green and now you've gone back on Disney
plus and you changed it and when I yell
at my grandkids someday and say they
didn't have it right the grandkids will
be like Grandpa you're crazy again what
color was it it was what do you mean no
way home it was bronze it was copper
yeah
oh wait okay and then Miss Marvel came
out it was green again they purposely
showed it it was green and we're all
like I think Miss Marvel was the one
that was placed in the weird one because
they also were like it's in She-Hulk but
it was like a weird timeline which do
you think like Kevin Frankie was lying
and he hadn't watched the show and he
just watched it like last weekend he was
like you guys make a bronze you guys
what the hell's going on
he does post production
why don't I use this Photoshop how do I
make it green again what are your
Instagram filters get one of your
Instagram like how aggressively New York
Kevin feige got in the progression
it's our Floridian brand it's my Uncle
Ben impression coming out
um he also you know Kevin or Jonathan
majors in a in a interviewer said was
talking about like his Inspirations for
King and he brings up Alexander the
Great who is heavily referenced in Moon
Knight yeah as like being the one
carrying around this like ancient
Talisman or whatever the MacGuffin was
so like I I love the idea that they're
seeding this science this whole thing of
like they're gonna insert King as Rama
into a history of the MCU that hasn't
been there currently
guarantee we'll get shots of some of
those hieroglyphics that have been
slightly like a different angle or
modified and like the way they did in
game when we went back and made Thor
dark World more relevant I guarantee
there's a lot of phase four that they're
going to enhance and they've already
instead of like phase one and two they
knew that Marvel was leading to
something but they didn't know how big
it was going to come by like one to
three there's a big leap in what it is
now they have the benefit of hindsight
so I guarantee there's been stuff in
phase four that are planning for like
phase six so I think Kang is going to be
an ability to and with digital you can
change the Statue of Liberty you can
change everything yeah it's very
exciting
but Brandon's going to get very upset
about every day hurry up so you can't
come change it they had shotguns not
radios don't change it don't change Mr
Falcon that that change I'm okay with uh
the super tents have been coming in
thank you endless Mike one three three
seven demanding mandatory fun guy uh
sabar is sending in a big suit which I
thank you so much uh Christian
unpronounceable saying I would very much
like Quake to join the MCU we very much
like it what Great Canadian politeness
tweet that at Chloe Bennett she was
having some Rush tweets going away
though a lot of support for her I if you
like Agents of Shield you'll love Agents
of Shield sure there's nothing wrong and
there's no other end to it uh xenix
standing on a Super Chat eat those fun
guys like your test baby yuck I'm good
too soon too soon too soon need a
battery it's a battery test uh oh and uh
Jamie Riley really liking my fart sounds
I ripped off yesterday that's good I
can't I can't be doing it every day we
gotta save them for special occasions
uh no I I refuse to give it to
um uh we do want to eat these mushrooms
and cheese maybe
if we do 100 do we each roll the dice no
no no it's one of them yeah well maybe
I'll make two people do it I'll do I'll
do it with you if we oh I'm doing it I
thought I would make two people do it I
didn't say I'd be one of those two
people uh I mean yeah keep sending those
super chats we're very excited to try
eating some of these some sweets some
nasty uh cheeses and fungi but one thing
we always love eating is Factor meals
yes yes uh and factor is here to help
you have a great year you can save time
and energy with factors ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
you get Factory you not only skip the
trip to the grocery store which we all
hate yeah you skip the chopping I gotta
chop my food I gotta prep my food we
gotta clean it up Factor gets that all
out of there their meals are fresh
they're never Frozen they've never seen
a freezer in their life my guy you
wouldn't believe it their meals are also
ready in just two minutes and you pop
them in the microwave beep beep the
future's making your food can you
believe it folks factors has meals that
are keto calorie smart vegan and veggie
they're also full of protein and
prepared by chefs and approved by
dietitians uh the meals are very
satisfying you'll feel very full they
got great ingredients that are clean
you're going to like it uh every week
they have like over 34 Chef prepared
dietitian approved uh options there's
always something new to try so you're
not going to get sick of the same old
stuff plus you can round out your meal
and replenish your snack Supply with an
assortment of over 36 quick bites
smoothies juices and more satisfying
add-ons if you want a little more if you
want to increase the factor of your your
Factor meals interesting uh you can
achieve and maintain your goals for this
year with Factor get America's number
one ready to eat meal kit and start
saving time eating well and living your
best life head to factormeals.com break
room 60 and use code break room 60 to
get 60 off your first box that's called
break room 60 at factorymails.com break
room 60 to get 60 off your first box of
factory meals if Tommy's going to do
it's gonna be in February Factor
February everyone dry February Factor
February
shortest month of the year okay
commitment to Excellence Tommy's gonna
make it happen he's gonna do it I'm
gonna get on those roller coasters at
Universal and I'm gonna wear that Verity
shirt I might just wear a huckberry
jacket while I'm at it oh sorry for
mandatory fun what no I do not want to
do it
for mandatory fun
it's time for mandatory fun
mandatory yes
on a show that's a little thin hit my
graphic again
a show it's so very nice we play the
graphic Thrice
yeah it's a show that never leaves you
wanting more play the graphic fall
uh
I just stopped playing the graphics you
don't get to mess with the format John
you do as I say or I stop the show when
it's trash don't stop this Jonas the
graphic begins or I stop no you want to
play chicken with me you want to play
chicken with me John please
oh no look at his face John just play
the graphic please play the graphic John
you're a Madman just play the graphic
this is good
now that's the internet quality right
there thank you submission now mandatory
fun is what I gather my three best
friends in the whole world to have a
little fun that they have no choice but
to participate in
no Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania is
just weeks away we have lots of great
content coming down the pike
[Music]
but until then I thought we'd make some
predictions okay and I'm doing
specifically post-credits okay
predictions I want you guys to think of
and Pitch me and I'm also going to go I
got one you got you got one one
post-credit scene that is grounded you
know probably gonna happen goes along
with what we've been seeing lately in
our post credit scenes and one break the
GD internet post-credit scene
that's going to make everybody go
okay
does anyone want to
a grounded one first okay go around and
then save save the big the big dogs okay
the big dog so you enjoy your grounded
one first yes uh my grounded one because
it just makes sense I I think they're
gonna go with a humorous funny and a uh
post credit scene and I think you're
going to see a still in the quantum
realm Modoc and it's still in the
quantum realm Bill Murray fighting over
who is in charge now the king okay okay
I like that very grounded okay very
believable very funny Jessica you want
to do yours you got a grounded one yes
um it's grounded but it's also not
grounded but it is pretty grounded okay
I I mentioned this on the break room
before I really want the post credit
scene to be Moda getting out of the
quantum realm I think everyone's gonna
get out of the quantity I need them out
of the quantum realm and I want him to
be at the college where the leader was
last seen in uh the old Hulk movies and
then we're getting closer to the
intelligence you have becoming one
does he approach a crown of hippies
playing hacky sack I want to play hacky
sack that's your hands is that Derek
crosses yeah he's gonna have a deeper
voice I don't think he
thinks I think he's gonna because he's
gonna be goofy he's gonna be Kevin Klein
he's gonna be Frank Grimes right so I
think they're gonna make fun of him I
don't think they'll give him a real bad
voice
we broke the Super Chat total ah let's
do our ground to produce
uh my grounded is it's a little out
there it's not it's not fully grounded
but I do think this is going to be
kicking off phase five you might have
two bigger but one is huge one is medium
huge uh I think this sets up Captain
Marvel so I think we've got the marbles
coming out it's one movie away I don't
think it's gonna tie to Guardians they
usually do one that kind of connects to
the next thing I think Guardians is
gonna be on its own so separate it's so
far out in space yeah they're Cosmic and
I so I see it skipping ahead to the
Marvels which is also Cosmic but I think
we're gonna find out that Kang might
have been responsible alongside the
eternals for the 10 Rings because it
looks like a lot of the timey stuff
involves a similar so I think we might
also find out the quantum band is one of
the same technology that came inside and
therefore when we see them body swap
it's because of something that is from
that time so I think there's some
element of a discovery of tech in the
film that then they have to explore
playing a little with the post credit
team to see the quantum ban tying
together that would allow you to jump to
the next movie a little Exposition but
it'll also be like it would anticipate a
film which they need to start doing
again like I I missed the post-credit
scenes that were kind of like remember
how excited you are for the next thing
as well as a big character they would
show clips yeah from future movies yeah
they shot the Civil War thing that was
like a separate angle they never even
used like I'd love to have more of that
again okay okay so some of the Marvels
tie in I like that so Kang's been
playing pretty pretty princess making
lots of jewelry I love that people could
wear I like that idea too bands yeah my
grounded things
I need the jewelry King uh I I did like
the idea of like because they did tease
and Sean she that like oh they're
reaching out to somewhere in space we
don't know uh if the ground did
post-credits scene is like yeah they get
out of the Quan around poop they're back
in their the lab and they're like oh we
did it good job guys good job is that
tank and Janet have stayed behind
because they're evil
um wait what they they turned out to be
evil you overlooked uh
credit uh and then there's like a knock
at the door and it's like shangshi and
it's like his bands are glowing he's
like I had to come here I don't know why
or it's Wong again Gathering people yeah
we should say and he's like what to do
and Scott's like I don't know I guess
I'm an Avenger why I like it that's my
grounded scene
okay well shall we uh
how do we decide who gets yeah who's
gonna stuck with it yeah I can do it
you're gonna roll and eat something
yeah run a poll
and I'll share my out there one minute
this is a little appetizer before the
appetizer now
my uh break theater that is okay Kang
has escaped we zoom out it's a room it's
a room of cloaked figures it's the
introduction of the Council of Kang
because they're like this king is messed
up and we got to figure out Council
can't kind of exists to help other kings
right like it's like they're like we got
to figure out what's going on here one
by one we get different Kang variants
until there's one main Kang and they're
like you know we're getting different
like versions of Jonathan Majors maybe
slightly altered then
the the the the cloak goes off
Angela Bassett Queen raimonda Kang
variant
she's back whoa she's back Oscar winner
Angela Bassett she's a king not that
romunda a different reminder for my
different Universe okay I like if they
were like she got the Oscar Nam and
feige was like we gotta get it
back
I'm just thinking of like who would who
would move the needle yeah
Spiderman as a king like just like a
shocking King in the Council of Kings if
someone we've already seen there's a
Kamala Khan I'm sorry no there is a
Kamala con King when uh Gamora flipped
the universe
[Laughter]
until February 1st and then I'm going to
turn your ass inside out now come on
come on yes come on gang when Gamora uh
put the world flipped it in two because
that's also how we got the Black Panther
Ghost Rider yeah
well she like I don't know what was the
term that she did but she like like a
book and then she closed the World
Superheroes mixed together so we got
ghosts like in Universe amalgam kind we
got ghost Panther uh which is Black
Panther and Ghost Rider and then we got
Kamala black panther oh we got uh and
then she flipped them again
I'm a vampire I'm a vampire
but it could be like a universe where
different people become Kang like you
talked about when it could be you know
maybe the Kamala King was really sick
yeah that's uh I did a rogue Theory
today that's gonna come out on the
weekend that's about that basically
about how they're directly linked to
each other the bands I'm telling you
there's something about the bands well
they're too close to not be together
yeah you know what I'm saying they have
to be something yeah a lot of Jewelers a
lot of jewelry a lot of afterlife what
if they were Hooper hoop earrings well
uh they went to a genre to pull and
Tommy and Jessica came out on top now
Tommy I feel like you walked yourself
into this I mean by asking for a poll
yeah well I don't know I didn't really
want to eat any of this awful looking
food but I will try I got five oh that's
the best one this one's five that's
white cheddar oh okay oh that's right
that was my nickname I think that's a
safe cheese
We Roll wow
we didn't get 12. check the book I think
there's a 12. yeah
yeah what's 12. I also got five
again you gotta roll again you guys are
only saying this because Tommy got the
one
oh no this is unexpected cheese
a nice dry portobello mushroom oh you
can't just get cheese with it
over here I think you get to our super
Chatters oh oh
let's let them cook let them cook
ing Joe
Ryan records Kyle schatzer cat GSU eagle
hanabaso a bunch of people we mentioned
before thank you again
oh Skyler Aldridge that's a good
question okay then we could um
can each of you Fan cast one last
comedian you want to see in coming of
chaos as a Witcher wizard what's up
all right uh do you have like a Break
scene okay okay so we introduced Scarlet
Centurion oh you were eating
at some point Scout Centurion he's
involved we've met him maybe only
briefly but then a post-credit scene
involves Scarlet century and trying to
figure out who he is or maybe he goes
back to his you know reality whether
it's time or Dimension and that's how
because Peyton Reed who is directing
this and I think might be done with
Marvel after this always wanted to
direct Fantastic Four movie I think he
goes back and the gift Kevin feige gave
him was he didn't get to direct
Fantastic Four but he gets to introduce
the Fantastic so he gets the
post-credits scene that brings in the
Fantastic Four Maybe by way of Doom
because we kept hearing rumors that it
was a doom post credit scene so maybe we
do have a doom post credit scene it's
just not in wakanda forever because that
would have been totally just not right
whereas this might work because it works
in time travel it works with dimensional
hopping and then we meet Fantastic Four
and maybe Doom in a post-credit team
which would break the internet and that
would I mean that'd be a huge February
to May is what three months that's
conversation for days okay and then you
can meet them maybe at Comic-Con the
cast comes out but I do think either
Fantastic Four or Doom or both
post-credits scene by way of scarlet
Centurion or okay okay okay I like it
that was such a that was such an old
lady night you're like
Jessica's starting to turn
my you guys I choked really bad on a
Twizzler earlier
yeah
they're more hazardous do you think with
your uh yeah I know it firsthand
experience do you think so you're
thinking that they would have the
wakanda forever like uh post credit but
just throw it in I think that we shot a
difference I think they like test
screened it we're like wait this movie's
been about sorrow and then we have like
a big exciting like it would have been
like really uncomfortable really sad in
the theater then like yeah well no the
Bucky and wakanda wasn't after wakanda
right it was before black panther uh
there was two buckies in wakanda one was
like when he first drops them off at the
Civil War not that one yeah and then
there's nothing yeah yeah
it's time to time to get back to work
yeah you've been hurting goats long
enough you've been okay perfect so I
could see like you know a setup because
also phase one did a lot of set up new
characters and like there's that Meme
that's always like someone jumps through
a portal and it's like I think they need
to go back to setting up future movies
and uh having a little bit more time in
their post-credits scene because if you
have people just show up it does feel
like hey Gladiators here all right
I think phase four was mainly also just
introduction to people right just
injuries even in the Disney Plus shows
but also in the post-credits scenes for
all the movies they were like here's
Hercules if you look at like phase one
through three phase one is very much
introductions like act one movie or play
but then two phase two is action setting
up consequences setting up catalysts
which should be Kang and then phase
three is gonna be all of that wrapping
up so I agree he's everyone said phase
four was a mess but I think you need the
act two and three of a movie to
understand the First Act it's all going
to come together they don't do things
accidentally
yeah you guys roll them so we have to oh
geez
sneakers hey oh it's that funky done
the funky dunkers
but I don't know
again I hope you get seven oh no
um
close to seven
we got 11 in the book I can't every time
I pierce it it gets smaller and smaller
five yeah no no no no
I'll keep rolling the curse of that
cheese
boy do you know how to roll a dice yeah
six six yeah mushrooms oh you got
mushrooms
how was yours oh oh Brandon that face oh
[Laughter]
baby the truth has gone bad I mean
technically all cheese has gone bad
[Music]
I like have that grittiness when you eat
like a straight from the ground
mushrooms I think these weren't washed
and that's okay it's a little fiber no I
did wash them a little dirt in mine
she's like okay
no I did I swear it gets in the inside
oh look at the tapes
mushrooms here's my break the internet
post credits oh it's okay there's cheese
and mushrooms everywhere uh here's my
break there and I post credit sequence
for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania okay
they get out okay they're back in their
little office okay again or whatever oh
stunning a portal opens I mean you're
joking portal opens yeah okay it's not a
sling ring portal it's a different
portal okay new new portal tank we did a
doom portal in uh Multiverse Madness
remember right Fantastic Four Mr Reed
used to do it through there and then in
the trailers we've seen the portals have
like weird purple smoke or whatever
stuff like that uh
through the portal comes
Chris Evans as Captain America Young
Chris Evans Captain America very alive
Robert Downey Jr Charlie Stark okay this
is a break for us Kevin feige is ready
to break the piece of emergency this
soon and they're like they're not ours
they're from a different timeline okay
but they're like it's not too late
like it's not too late to save this one
or whatever they've been going around
saving other ones got it there's some
like leftover Avengers that the ones
left alive and Kevin feige is like look
we're gonna put Assets in C for phase
five okay and we're gonna go big well
this is gonna get Twitter going crazy
and variety you're not invited because
you'll spoil it oh God that's right okay
we should have kept eating the cheese I
rolled again for this I'm trying to give
you we're allowed to roll I'm trying to
give them their money's worth it's been
a long time I will say I yeah I ate that
cheese and it was so bad I had to stick
it up I was trying to break the internet
with your post credit scene I think um
that uh Kamala Khan's gonna end up in
the quantum realm and she's stuck in
there
oh that broke the internet what's she in
there with how by yourself Kesha no it's
Kesha and come on
stop bringing the KKK into this I mean
you guys started it how did we learn it
you guys started it that's all I'm
saying
all of us I also I do love your idea
though of King being involved with a
Fantastic Four because I still want this
Fantastic Four movie to be like 60s
fantastic yeah I want it to be a time
but I don't watch the whole movie to be
in the 60s and have to be like oh there
was a baxter building yeah right we
forgot there was a stretchy man in the
60s okay what I want is like there was a
king that got that family because they
were the biggest threat to him right
stolen from the 60s and they come back
and it's very much like blast from the
past and they've been stuck we're still
in the 60s right Fish Out of Water what
what's the phone what's a cell phone I
don't know Google who's that but we can
quickly catch up to technology yeah and
then and then a kid on the street goes
your name's Mr Fantastic what are you
some kind of stripper you know they make
the name joke you just got to make the
name jokes what is that thing yeah
foreign
visible woman
what is he a human
door
don't barf your fermented cheese all
over the place from under my nuts
but I do like all these ideas
I think some of these grounded ones
could work yeah some of these break the
internet ones I don't know except for
mine it's perfect
I think you're you're closer to what
they're gonna get for King Dynasty I
mean I think it sets up we have to
Imagine by Secret Wars or King Dynasty
we're gonna see Chris Evans and Robert
Johnson I'm wondering if we see you
again Junior earlier in ironheart as an
AI oh AI because he's the voice in her
yeah he's her Jarvis a-i-r-d-j uh her
best friend's gonna be in it and her
friends killed and she'll be the voice
do you think they're gonna go that way
yeah
the whole time I think she develops it
uh using like uh you know one of these
AI programs she uses some recordings of
his voice and fakes it and then Pepper
Pot Souza see I think he's like oh yeah
I think he's a narcissist that
downloaded his reality into the helmet
at the end of end game when he pops up
and he gives that message to his
daughter I think it's his whole
personality so she finds his helmet and
puts it on boom down a junior who finds
it oh
like Tony Stark wants to be immortal so
he would do everything he could to be
immortal himself but digitally I never
got my happy ending three thousand
so now you're gonna pay in court
Riri Williams is she where the um the
rescue suit to court the whole time but
that's also a way that you know Disney
can have Downy get to leave and then if
he wants to come back they can do it
like so they don't have to show the
download of helmet but then they can
just show a little scene what do we get
first Doctor Doolittle 2 or Robert
Downey Jr
guy Richie is doing two movies this year
like he's got two films coming out and
then I think he's doing a big Disney one
and then I think after that Sherlock
three
what he's got two he's got a Jake
Gyllenhaal movie this year what's the
Disney one oh I think he's doing um
Hercules the live-action
pepper pots and everyone's just sniffing
they're like
what's that smell and she's like I've
lit six of my Gwyneth Paltrow candles
here that would be interesting for her
to research herself well no there's a
Gwyneth Paltrow in her University oh wow
okay like in Ocean's Eleven or ocean 12
where Julia Roberts also exists and the
character I like that I love that scene
we love a Multiverse we love a
Multiverse uh thank you to our super
Checker super Chatters the cheese is
starting to go to my brain I think there
was too much cold in there everything
tasted bad in there it's very bulky uh
Ryan Recker thank you brag about the
light they've is koi they love the break
room Jorge Garcia I want a Fantastic
Four to start in the 60s they travel
back in time facing Rama time oh we're
going even further back in the end when
they try to go back to the present day
they get stuck in a Time Vortex they get
pulled out in present day
the Fantastic Force they could defeat
Kang and that whole universe could get
imploded and we have an out of universe
Fantastic Four like we could literally
have a universe get destroyed by Kang
and they're like instead of being you
know trapped in space they're trapped
multi-dimensionally maybe in the
negative Zone which they could introduce
by way like the Negative Zone could be
introduced in Ant-Man through the
quantum realm right and then because
they're pretty synonymous so you can
introduce the Negative Zone and they've
been trapped in the negative Zone
because they're Multiverse got destroyed
so they got really really small in order
to protect themselves and maybe when
they grow that's Cosmic radiation boom
they got powers there's a lot of options
there's a lot going on in that story a
lot going on if there's the negative
zone mean there's a positive Zone
somewhere are we we're on the positive
Zone I don't feel like not in this time
left but I don't feel it every day I I
yeah I like it you can work like it
someone's got to stop these fantastic
What's Happening Here how many people
here came to watch the break room
tonight not many not many how many
people came here to watch the bad guy
Razor Ramon back back from the dead is
he dead yet Scott Hall died
that's our Channel because of Jessica
and Eric's wand division after show
those were the days this Channel and all
of you guys have helped me through some
hard times what guys are here we're
sorry for the hard times we hope they're
all better times now uh this was the
question we were going to come back to
Skyler Aldrich asking can each of you
Fan cast one last comedian you want to
see in Covenant of chaos as a witch or
wizard yes as you know there's a lot of
people that cast this movie uh or in the
show uh Sasha rare Cohen not necessarily
cast for this show but rumors that
playing Mephisto that have not been shot
down yet starting an iron hard Aubrey
Plaza obviously joining the cast
probably as a witch what's another
comedian and you'd like to see enter as
like a witch or a wizard uh this is one
that uh is this Scott house pick hey
this is one of the bad guys gonna say to
you one thing I know about
coven of chaos is they don't have the
gadget guy yet okay that's where Carrot
Top comes in who's the ultimate bad guy
the guy with all the gadgets huh for
live I'm surprised you didn't pick
Andrew Dice Clay Razor Ramon
I don't know me and The Dice Man had a
weird threesome with Faye Dunaway oh
okay oh that's that's that's pretty good
that's pretty good
let's just say well what is that oh
what's that gang she was part of Bonnie
and Clyde let's say she she got shot at
him all right all right all right
no more Q-tips
okay so he's already in the Disney
family okay uh he's my favorite comedian
he's someone who's yep I mean obviously
the narc himself he's uh he's a comedian
who uh brings us a very specific charm
and an aggression to it you got the very
uh specific
um Aubry Plaza we've got a very specific
at the Harkness massage bar and Cohen
certainly specific I think you needed a
new flavor and space Boston's already
been established bring in Bill
burrito
no no no no no no no and you know what's
nearby Boston from Salem it's happening
oh she's from Salem they go by Boston
yeah yeah wizard Boston's waiting for
you I like it right there
him just yelling drinking like a coffee
and throwing it out unless he's paying
pay spot Pete in Spider-Man three and
then I'm happy whatever whatever you
need to do we're just gonna bring in
crazy people I say just throwing Ray
Romano Ray Romano
it would be funny if Ray was living true
if Raymond of Everybody Loves Raymond
lives in Westfield
all right man what is happening so what
happens when there's no news
in the mushrooms
when we were waiting on James Gunn to
drop news this is what happens
here's who you should add to the cast
here's who you should add to the cats a
comedian uh having a Resurgence never
really went away let's give my let's
make him a wizard he can play a
character if he wants to a man of a
thousand faces Martin shortly yeah
Steve Martin gets enough what Martin
Short have this one dog uh we've gone on
way too long you guys are sick of it the
mushrooms are getting to our brain the
smell of the cheese is driving us nuts
he's tired of us yeah uh thank you for
tuning in to the break room today again
like And subscribe to the channel if you
haven't already like this video uh we
appreciate guys for hanging out with us
today we hope you've had a great
Wednesday join us here tomorrow we'll be
live again right here from our very own
break room at new Rockstar's
headquarters and Manitoba we appreciate
you all watching the show today tune in
the channel uh Whitney's got a breakdown
of the new Dungeons and Dragons sure uh
gonna hit the channel any second now if
it hasn't already hit and we have lots
more great content coming on the channel
uh tune in tomorrow same time we'll see
you then have a great rest of your day
adios latest Gators goodbye
[Music]
thank you